we had so many one-on-one little horsey
we had one emotional goodbye and we have
the windmill twice this is your
bachelorette recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rose say hi
everybody i'm lauren zima and i'm dead
okay I'm alive but what an emotional
episode of write one on one after one on
one goodbye after goodbye don't drink
for everyone on one don't drink for
every exit oh wow okay it's me I am here
because I had to devote an entire vlog
so that we could properly pay the
respect to something that has become
instantly iconic what else
the windmill moments oh the reveal was
so powerful everybody my jaw drops did
yours I don't think there's been
anything in this franchise's story
history that has become so quickly so
unforgettable and quotable and Hannah
brown I want you to know that we stand
you and that we stand with you and I
know that those two things mean the same
thing but I think it's worth saying
twice here's why this is a woman who on
camera in front of millions is talking
about being in touch with and proud of
her sexuality this is a woman who will
not be shamed nor defined by someone
else's religious beliefs and this is a
woman who is arguably changing the very
cultural status of windmills in our
great nation's history Hannah
we applaud you up or with you we thank
you now I know that you guys were
instantly analyzing episode going back
through finding windmills to determine
when this could have happened was it in
Amsterdam or is it coming up in Greece
and here's my thought I think if it
happened in Amsterdam we would have seen
it last night why not then the audience
would have been in on it and we would
have then observed as Hannah let Luke in
on what happened on Sam
so my guess is it happens in Greece and
also I've done a lot of research aka
Google imaging and it looks like there
are a lot of windmills in Greece just
saying so let me know your thoughts and
EE a fun little game a little drink
we like to do here on roses and Rosie
please drink responsibly we have put
windmills throughout the roses and Rosie
episodes so drink every time you see a
windmill let me know what you guys
thought of the episode and of course we
will be talking about the rest of the
episode because other stuff happened to
love you guys so much here we go
let's get into it you know what drink
for every Pope first time it's ever
happened although first I do quickly
want to say that I know I still my Rosie
last week and it was a sand on my part
you guys and I know that faith is a big
part of this season of that sure let's
not get down on that territory I don't
worry about it later but anyway so I
took you guys advice I heard it I put my
wine in a stemless glass today for extra
stability because right now I don't
trust myself just can't trust herself I
don't know her I don't know what did
they do I also didn't put ice in the
glass because a lot of you said that ice
adds condensation to the outside of the
glass which may have contributed to my
slippage and I want to thank you guys
for your support I want to thank you for
your advice I want to thank you for your
words and for your tears I will probably
still put my ice in my wine still in my
life because I feel like it hydrates
that's such a ratchet explanation anyway
I also want to thank the Latvians
because there were a couple of Latvians
who messaged me and said no naked bungee
jumping is not a Latvian tradition thank
you for your service thank you very
history okay so we are in the
Netherlands and don't drink for every
flower oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
Mandy Hanna says she's excited to be
past the drama it feels really good to
be
but is she dad you want to go on a date
with me today yes then Jack gets a
one-on-one and someone says off-camera
did he bring his guitar didn't bring his
guitar did he I hope not I hope not and
I said lol performance after performance
okay I know myself I'm gonna do
everything I can to make sure that time
isn't robbed for myself and you guys
mostly Rob from Hanna
exactly Luke is talking about getting
time with Hanna and Tyler says that most
importantly for Hanna she needs time
with the guys and I just want to stand a
supportive man Tyler we see you and we
appreciate you because women got to
support women but men got to support
women - so we're kicking off the episode
overall what did you guys think of it
let me know in the comments below but
first we have a one-on-one date with
Jeff
well that's come out about Jed hasn't it
and I just want to tell you guys I see
your messages I see your messages about
rumors about Peter - and we have a lot
of the show left I will say that I'm
very excited to ask very pointed
questions when I do get the chance to
interview them whatever that may be
[Music]
okay will you accept this pansy I will
so we have the day date with jet show
you are English
English American America okay and of
course they made a beautiful older
couple straight from central casting and
the couple asks them how long have they
been together and Jen says long enough
to know things
long enough to know things yeah not
everything now all right and you guys
watching this date through the lens of
what we've heard is so crazy isn't it
because so much about this date went
great I felt like we were seeing Hannah
have real emotional feelings for a guy
other than Luke for the first time on
the show what did you think of he has
feelings for Jen these films have been
so easy
they were both singing feelings come so
easy effortless feelings yeah Hannah
basically told him when she's with the
other guys she's thinking about him and
then at dinner Jenna was saying a lot of
beautiful things about them building a
powerful foundation of a relationship
foundationally powerful relationship but
about him taking on burdens for her and
then they both said they were falling in
love with each other I'm falling in love
with you I mean I was wrapped up in the
sweetness but you know now it's like am
i watching a documentary or am i
watching fiction oh my gosh this is real
it's hard to know another yikes moment
on the date though Hannah says that Jed
makes her feel safe and secure just
write us a song Jed oh and Jed says
she's got to meet the Wyatt family and
that's wild isn't it because I
interviewed Jed's ex and she said that
Jed had talked to his mom about their
relationship so what's Jed's family
gonna think when they need Hannah do you
think they knew that allegedly Jed went
on the show just for his career he's
gonna bring Hannah home and talk about
like real feelings is he gonna give them
an FYI in the corner
No okay all right this is the episode of
the guys in plain t-shirts drink for
every time you see a plain t-shirt not
that I'm complaining
Tyler seeing a tee pilot pee anity Mikey
and of T no complaints from me who looks
best in a t-shirt
anyway hey what's up okay then we get
the one-on-one date with Tyler drinks
for everyone on one know which is your
favorite one on one and it's Tyler ah no
[ __ ] but more importantly it's Tyler
lifting Hannah up on that horse oh my
god it is sexy to watch and he supports
her figuratively and literally so but it
turns out Tyler not great on a horse
what are you doing great and hilarity
ensues I don't know why they didn't have
some kind of a guide you know if you're
on one of those dates on a horse on the
beach that the show's done before the
horse can only go straight it can only
go down the beach but in the city it's
like the horse is like where do I go and
more importantly what snacks stand do I
go to I appreciated Hannah's desire for
snacks on this date I get it I got it
who doesn't want to snack a waffle and
ice cream but trying to come to you I
got something for you I don't know how
easy it is to procure a snack whilst on
a horse it seems difficult it's for
large horses the snack they end up
getting is a big old bite of pickled
herring isn't it single herring is they
one of my worst nightmares and our boy
Tyler almost throws I was sort of
wondering where the producers thinking
Tyler's coming across too perfect they
like we gotta make it more awkward like
he's got to be unable to do an activity
and he's got a like puke on camera but I
do want to say we Stan a supportive man
while Tyler was almost puking he was
grabbing Hannah's plate for her and
taking it for her god please don't let
there be a scandal with Tyler Tyler see
he proud to be scandal-free please I
can't take any more this season wish but
so much myself a month of ever
let you guys I'm exhausted but also
captivated is this the best season of
The Bachelor ever ok don't drink every
time I ask you to let me know in the
comments below
Jesus mm-hmm religion on the show
stop it Lauren anyway so I'm gonna stay
with Tyler Hannah is pushing him for
more digging in she's like I want to
know what's going on here like what's
going on yeah think I like me too
what's going on in that big beautiful
brain and Tyler opens up and drink for
every time ish got real this episode
Tyler talked about some real stuff I
filled up my isolation ship not gonna
lie but I needed to fail I'm thankful
for my fails finally right we need to
get to know the guys we need to get to
know Hannah as well why is this a phrase
you guys is this thing we're saying I'm
the show now or in life now are we
saying I'm falling in love for you
what's happening is it an inside joke
that the producers are having us
partaken okay I'm falling in love for
you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
there are a lot of questions I have and
I'm sure like she wants to get to know
you better
and you know we have to remember Conners
here and drink every time Connor says
something hopeful that's sad I really do
need that one-on-one day to get to know
her better
Connor is bum's cuz he doesn't get a
one-on-one like it's disappointing
drinks for every time Connor doesn't get
a one-on-one and he goes to Hannah but
we see on her face what she's thinking
don't we it's too little too late you
know basically it's kind of too little
too late and Connor goes home if I can
see Connor by oh my god we are so sad to
see you go but we hope to get more from
you in Paradise love Connor
you know it's just two minutes
right okay Mike said something
interesting he said he didn't give a
crap about Connor are you to crash the
economy and get the 101 but I do fill
form as an individual as a human being
but also felt bad for him as a human
drink every time ish got real seen a
different side of Mike this episode is
[Music]
next up speaking of the one on one with
my hmm and we are going Viking Viking
with my king
you guys I love a biking date oh my gosh
I loved this so much I mean they've got
baskets what did the basket snacks
what's in the baskets wine hi what is so
bad are we gonna bike to a port are we
gonna get on a sailboat at that port
we're gonna have our snacks and wine on
the bike and in a picnic and that other
sailboat oh my god excited she's wrong
to me as I'm drawn to her turns out no
we're gonna learn about art you like art
and we're gonna ask if we like art I
love his art who doesn't like art who's
like nay
I hate a painting but you know we are
drawn but are we drawn to Mike with
Hanna
hope she feels the same way about me as
I do for her the answer is and
and no like no she's never gonna meet
his Nana and his mom she's not the
fourth lady okay the arch becomes
powerful the arts becomes poignant after
their day date Hanna is looking at art
in a museum and she is crying and we are
seeing that very famous painting the
girl with the Pearl Earring and then
we're cutting back to Hanna and we're
looking in that woman's eyes and then
we're looking at Hanna's eyes it's a lot
of camera work Hanna is crying from the
minute Mike gets off that glass elevator
isn't she oh my god
you guys I have to tell you this date
was a first for me I have never cried
while watching the show but I teared up
I did do I have a heart
[Music]
well we it's really clear that I want
Hannah to be my wife
Mike is saying that he's ready for
Hannah to be his wife she says can we
just go sit down and talk just go sit
down and talked so I can break up with
you we know what's coming I could see
like you just like got me through it and
Hannah is going through the memories
with Mike and drink for each memory I
know one of the first conversations we
had was like you don't want to like it's
your artwork and while I appreciate her
paying respect to their connection each
memory feels like a stab in the heart
doesn't it I'll bet that hurts
Hannah was crying and I felt so bad for
how she felt and Mike handled it so well
yeah I was crying Mike wasn't crying
Mike didn't cry in the limo or anything
you know not everybody cries but what
did you guys think was Mike really upset
do you now want Mike for bachelor let me
know in the comments below then we get a
group date with Peter with Garrett okay
and what's weird here is the stakes
still feel low don't they because I
can't get out of my head this shot in
the trailer where Luke and Hannah are so
clearly in grease and they're not in
grease they're in the Netherlands
they're in The Hague which interestingly
is where international war criminals are
sent to be tried for their crimes but
they're not in Greece are they so I
don't feel like Luke's going home here
tonight guys uh and I don't think Peters
going home because we know what Peter
the chemistry is a 10 out of 10 so
Garrett writings on the world good I
know for a fact right now
I will not go home because of loopy but
we are sure gonna drink for every time
some kind of ominous statement is made
that definitely indicates that Garrett's
going home I saw the look on her face
and your time is coming to an end
okay this seems to be one of those dates
where maybe production might be tired at
this point and like the date activity is
that we're gonna sit around in a room
but we have line and charcuterie that
comes into play later in a way that I
don't appreciate don't disrespect good
charcuterie we did so Luke sits now with
Anna and they start talking with the
other guys immediately how's this week
been it's been I just I I hate talking
about the other guys you know I don't
have to say any names Luke then seems to
be like blaming Hanna for the way that
the guys don't like him I screw time
that I robbed them time with you guess
what they all turn on me hate me and
start saying some crap that's totally
fake not sure about me and it's the
thing I've been dealing with this whole
time that's the only reason why it is
like me that's the truth I need more
wine let me say you know I like to think
idea thing Luke Stone gets a little
unsettling doesn't oh I just put my wine
in my notes and I thought I was covered
I thought I'd taking care of myself
what's happening to me all right Luke
says that he knows Hannah I like to
think I do but I'm a little unsettled by
his tone was I the only one on settled
by Luke's tone here
it just felt uncomfortable is this how
Hannah feels is this when she gets
confused is this why she doesn't know
what to do with Luke is our my inside
his head right now oh my gosh I don't
like being here I gotta get out of here
oh my god and I feel for you I where are
you help me support me Luke talks to Han
about the guys and then Hanna has to
talk to Garrett about Luke I just talked
to Lee and Luke in the meantime eats an
entire piece of salami in one bite and
then oh my god
Garrett and Luke are talking you talked
to her about me
again and the music is going and I'm
thinking I've seen this scene before and
oh my god the screaming yes don't drink
every time they say good good good
yeah it is good it's very good it's very
very good and don't drink every time
Garrett points at Luke it's your fault
you talk about everybody you're the
fakest person I've ever met I know you
now double point on that one double
pistol I know you but drink during the
whole screaming moment I am never and
I'm not ever going to reach for anything
I've been nothing but truthful with
Hanna and you are not gonna mess it up
okay I'm not gonna mess it up
did Luke lie to Garrett about his
conversation with Hanna it seems like he
did roll the tape she asked me what I
thought about you god I wish I could
roll the tape on this show what this is
right here this is a pile of baloney and
then oh my god I truly died
you've been saying to me and oh my god
Luke through the Bologna at him
I am deceased and oh sweet Jesus Garrett
says I'll put it back
Garrett don't do that that meat has been
in your crotch and multiple people's
hands my body is buried and oh my god
Garrett is in his ITM still holding the
meat my soul has left the universe so
man what's up yeah now Luke is talking
to Peter and don't drink every time they
say baloney baloney
it's baloney like that just like it
doesn't end you know what I've had a
hard time understanding Hannah's
attraction to Peter cuz I think Peter
seems great but I'm not seeing like sexy
Peters baloney I mean we literally
talked about this like but I saw sexy
Peter here I felt like he was assertive
with Luke but mature you like
essentially gave me your word
he was clear with Luke but grounded your
stay in your lane like you were only
focusing on your relationship with
Hannah he was emphatic with Luke but not
dramatic it's not how I wanted to spend
my possible last date everything okay
Peter I see you I want to do this first
say someone who always just makes me
feel special important Hannah says Peter
is a nice freak and gives him a rose and
that makes all the sense in the world
doesn't it it's no baloney this is
beautiful
back to Garrett and Luke and Garrett
turns savage and he says Luke are you
licking your lips because you're
attracted to me
can your lips because you're attracted
to me and I don't have a soul it's lost
in the ether garret fabulous television
Garret okay then dinner with Garrett
Luke and Hanna and poor Hanna she sounds
so stressed out during this toast she's
but there's so much hate no we're sorry
today it was hard tonight is going to be
harder Luke says that things didn't go
as well as he thought they would know
that today things that go as good as I
had thought they would do they ever have
they ever once not once
really not since like day once de Luke's
you know anyway it's not easy for me to
talk about it because I I hated like
chasing those selfish like fleshly
desires right but then he and Hanna do
have a powerful conversation in which
they talk about faith and in which Luke
also says that no it wasn't like
overnight it wasn't like over and I I'm
just this perfect person Luke does that
mean you think you're a perfect person
now but you know what their fate
connects them up tonight it to him Hanna
said it so we're with Hanna we've got a
support Hanna back to dinner uh and
Garrett tells Hanna he loves her I love
you
what did you guys think of Garrett
saying the l-word to Hanna
the fact that Garrett said it before Jed
or Tyler or Peter felt a little wild to
me and I'm not sure it felt a little bit
like a what's the sports term a Hail
Mary yeah I don't want to demean his
feelings but I wasn't believing it and
Hanna I don't want to shock anyone gives
the rose to Luke and then this goodbye
with Garrett is so weird it's even less
emotional than the goodbye with Mike
even though Garrett just told her I
loved you then Garrett's in the car and
Garrett is so blank drink for Garrett's
blank stare yikes
his soul has also left his body I think
it's probably hanging out with
translucent ghosts Dylan hopefully
paradise then we get the trailer and we
are praying over Luke and we have
shirtless Tyler and Tyler is in love
with Hannah I am in love with Hannah
brown and Peter brings Hannah on my
sailing date of course he does we'll
take any mode of transportation with you
pilot Pete by air or by sea huh
and Peter is in love with Hannah things
have heated up and over with shirtless
Tyler again I'm having so many emotions
where is my body where is my brain drink
every time we're shirtless and we are
shirtless with Jed and his guitar the
guitar even made it into the shirtless
moment huh I'll never lie to Hanna
[Music]
and then Hannah just said she in a
windmill twice we did it the second time
Hannah Hannah cheers to you girl you do
you I have died many times today twice
at least yeah I applaud you I appreciate
you were here for you I cannot wait to
see what is next on this show you guys
by the way everybody I am on cameo the
app where you can get a message for me
please buy one if you'd like I will sing
you a fabulous song leave me details I
like to make it fun and of course every
Tuesday morning at 10 a.m. Pacific we
are on e to you live with a special
guest from bachelor nation dog and about
the episode I love you guys so much
thank you so much for watching I hope
that all of your souls are still within
your bodies
[Music]
here lies a wanted who brought a lot of
laughter a lot of joy a lot of hope to
the bachelor nation a woman who consumed
a lot of rose a I mean a lot guys
[Music]
[Music]